durante el experimento de deshidratación
lt no gaseoso y el etanol que no
reaccionó pasaron por el tubo y a través
del agua lt no fue recolectado
cuantitativamente como un gas pero no el
etanol que no reaccionó explica esta
observación en términos de las fuerzas
internos leku lares entre el agua y cada
uno de los dos gases y sólo para saber
de lo que estamos hablando veamos la
instalación original que nos dieron al
inicio de este problema aquí nos están
diciendo que al calentar el etanol y el
catalizador reacción y una parte del
etanol se transforma en eterno pero como
no reacciona todo el etanol de hecho en
una parte del problema que habíamos
visto que obtuvimos un rendimiento del
60 punto algo por ciento así que aquí
tenemos una combinación de etanol y eten
o gaseoso que pasan por este tubo se
enfrían y pasan a través del agua
entonces nos están diciendo okay parece
que solamente estamos observando lt no
gaseoso y porque no podemos ver el
etanol gaseoso bueno la razón es que se
las voy a decir pero ahorita la escribo
la razón es que el etanol gaseoso es más
soluble en agua porque recuerden que el
etanol es una molécula polar y el agua
es un solvente polar así que se puede
disolver mucho mejor en el agua que el
éter porque el este no no es una
molécula polar entonces vamos a escribir
de hecho el eterno como que se burbujea
mientras que el etanol se disuelve
entonces nos dicen explica esta
observación en términos de las fuerzas
internos leku lares entre el agua y cada
uno de los gases bueno primero vamos con
el etanol
etanol el etanol es polar
polar
así que se disuelve
se disuelve
en el agua
se disuelve en el agua mucho mejor que
el eterno
que el eterno
que no es polar que no
es polar
así que podemos decir que el etanol
esta noche
y el agua
forman puentes de hidrógeno
que los podemos dibujar si quieren miren
pongamos una molécula de etanol por acá
este es el oxígeno y después tenemos el
hidrógeno y por acá tenemos el c2 h5
entonces este lado de la molécula es
parcialmente negativo y este lado es
parcialmente positivo y por acá el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
carbono y aunque la diferencia es menor
que entre el oxígeno y el hidrógeno esta
parte también es parcialmente positiva
bueno pero no tan positiva como esta
parte y entonces cuando tenemos
moléculas de agua vamos a poner una por
aquí
esta es una molécula de agua y aquí
tenemos cargas parciales positivas y por
acá tenemos una carga parcial negativa
por lo tanto se forma este puente de
hidrógeno este es un puente de hidrógeno
entonces el etanol se disuelve en agua
mientras que con lt no como es no polar
sólo ocurren interacciones dipolo dipolo
inducido vamos a escribir
lt na
el eterno
no polar no polar
entonces
entonces sólo tendrá interacciones
dipolo dipolo inducido
o mejor solo vamos a decir dipolo porque
el agua es polar y aún cuando lt no es
una molécula simétrica y tiene un doble
enlace no tiene polaridad aunque hay
partes de la molécula de teno que son un
poco más negativas que otras
particularmente si observan estos
carbonos de aquí son un poco más electro
negativos que los hidrógenos pero como
lt no es no polar sólo tiene
interacciones interacciones dipolo
inducido o solamente dipolo con el agua
con el agua polar y es por eso por eso
que el eterno no se disuelve en agua y
es por eso que el eterno
no se disuelve
y las burbujas salen y las burbujas
sal
entonces mientras que el etanol se
disuelve en el agua las burbujas de té
no salen porque no tienen interacciones
tan fuertes con el agua